do you ever have doubts if so how do you
handle them yeah I talked about the
doubt I had answering that second
question if you don't have any doubt I'm
gonna be real suspect of you as a person
so do we all have doubts hey folks sorry
to break it to you Jocko occasionally
has doubts he'll never admit it right
but doubts are part of being human and
if you're not doubting yourself you're
not challenging yourself either I
believe this is just what I think so I
try to approach my doubts head-on
unflinching you know did I have doubt
this third time I got sent into battle
school yeah big time but put on the best
uniform put on you know get in the best
shape polish your boots to the highest
standard be prepared to get [__] on and
and and Bulldog your way through and
smile while you're eating that [__]
sandwich you know like the doubt is you
ever heard that like you ever talk to
someone and they talk about what they
want they really want to be doing okay
so I have a I have a buddy of mine he's
a cop but he really wants to sell
t-shirts and he's like I'm just wait
there's you know there's a time there's
a time he even made a t-shirt for me and
he's probably gonna listen to this and
he knows who he is and bro I told you
this at the time he said let's sign a
contract for 12 months and this I'm like
you know I don't um six months tops and
you know if that he's like why what's
the matter I'm like why just I just
don't think you're gonna this is it this
is where your are he's like why and I'm
like because you're not putting the
effort like you're cop you're not a
t-shirt seller and he's easy you see
he's doubting himself to take that leap
you know did I have a doubt when I put
my name in for the election
hell yeah I did I've never been a
politician I was a gunfighter I was a
sniper but okay I deal with doubt by
dealing with the situation does that
make sense yeah because I want to know
that I can a get through this through it
and if I fail I fail that's hey man I
fail all the time I failed reading your
book I failed Megan to the airport in
time yesterday but and I have doubt all
the time but I also have enough
confidence in myself that I'm willing to
try almost anything and I don't know if
that's really the question that was
asked but the answer is the same because
fear is the thing that holds you back
from almost anything in your life it was
i nervous when I put my hand up to
volunteer to go on sniper course hell
yeah I was but where did I want to be I
wanted to be a sniper course it was i
nervous the first time I was in charge
of a sniper team going into combat
uh-huh but guess what
there's nowhere else I wanted to be
doubt is your doubt is your mind telling
you you know to think about the things
you need to think about anyway right
like the doubt is there for a reason
it's the self-preservation mechanism and
you need to use that doubt to put the
thoughts into your mind to visualize the
successful outcome like we talked about
earlier visualization you know I I
picked your failure all the time and
then I picture how will I deal with it
you know doubt doubt to me is just a
question to ponder and then move on you
know so that's that's how I do it I'm
gonna say for me I agree the doubt is
really how I know that I'm pushing
myself into a zone that I'm not used to
but like the enemy
I respect my doubts I'm not afraid of
them but I respect them I'm gonna watch
him I'm gonna listen to him I'm gonna
understand my doubts but I'm not gonna
be afraid of them and I'm gonna destroy
them